now weather forecasters say that
hurricane laura
which has made land in texas and
louisiana from the gulf of mexico
could cause a storm surge which they're
describing as
unsurvivable nbc reporter jay gray joins
us now from lake charles
in louisiana just bring us up to date
with the very latest we can just about
make you out in the pictures
[Applause]
yeah the old things have really
intensified here over the last hour or
so this storm has made landfall
about 30 miles to the south of where we
are in cameron louisiana
which means that eye is targeting where
we are in lake charles
strong severe winds 150 miles an hour at
the core of this storm
and understand that we're just seeing
the beginning of this this is not as bad
as things are going to get
here as hard as that may be
we're also seeing the rains pick up
dramatically here
and there's that score surge you talked
about a 20-foot wall of water
as we get another strong gust here
20-foot wall of water
pushing inland as much as 30 miles
it's going to cause catastrophic damage
along the coast
and it is going to be rough here as well
for the next
several hours as that eye wall makes its
way across this area lake falls
that's when we'll see the most severe
conditions that's still hours away
and understand this is a massive storm a
category four
it is in fact the most powerful storm
they've seen in this region
and it's a region that deals with
hurricanes on a pretty regular basis
here
it's going to continue to be intense as
it moves through and
inland and then back to the east and
eventually out to the east coast
we're going to see millions without
power if it holds this intensity
and continues its path and we are going
to see flooding
that is going to span several states
neil
jay thank you very much for bringing us
up today make sure that you and the team
do stay
safe